شركات التكنولوجيا الكبرى تخوض سباقا قويا
لدمج تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي في
منتجاتها وتعزيز تجربه المستخدمين
والمعركه بدات في نوفمبر الماضي عند اطلاق
تشارت مايكروسوفت ضخت عشره مليارات دولار
من الاستثمارات في شركه اوبن اي المسؤوله
عن شات جي بي تي على ان يدعم روبوتو
الدردشه نتائج متصفحها بنك اما جوجل
فاطلقت بارد هي خدمه محادثات تجريبيه
مدعومه من نموذج اللغه لندن الذي اعلنت
عنه الشركه في 2021 تقول جوجل ان اداها
ستتمكن من شرح اكتشافات جديده مثل تلسكوب
جيمس الفضائي لطفل يبلغ من العمر 9 سنوات
ايضا ستكسر حواجز اللغه في ترجمه جوجل متى
تراقب المنافسين وتعمل على معالجه
المشكلات الاوليه في اطلاقها وتدعي ان احد
اصداراتها لامع
يعمل بشكل افضل من نموذج تشات لكن لا ما
ليست التجربه الاولى لميتا في اغسطس
الماضي مثلا اطلقت برنامج بلندر بوت ولم
يكن بالكفاءه المطلوبه كما اطلقت جلاكتيا
المصمم لكتابه المقالات العلميه وفشله بعد
ثلاثه ايام فقط من طرحه
[موسيقى]